WE WILL GO AHEAD AND START OUR
HUMAN SERVICES --
COMMITTEE MEETING AT SIX FIFTEEN
CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE ARE HERE.
BACK TO TRY HERE.
BUT I'M GONNA [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND.
WE HAVE QUIRK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE SB ONE THIRTY FOR A BI
HERNANDEZ --
REGIONAL CENTER CONTRACTS.
BY MISTER RUDY SALAS.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR HERNANDEZ SENATE
BILL.
ONE THIRTY FOUR A SO BILL ONE
THIRTY FOUR DEALS WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS WERE TRYING TO BRING
MORE TRANSPARENCY THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT.
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING IN KERN
COUNTY.
AND THAT TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
AND WITH THE MOTION AND THE
SECOND I APPRECIATE THAT FOR MY
COLLEAGUES ALL.
HOW DEFERRED TO THE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON THE HALF ELF'S YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA --
THE BILL IS PRETTY CLEAR AND
SIMPLE IT DOES IT DOES TWO
THINGS ONE IT SAYS.
THAT PEOPLE WHO GET PUBLIC MONEY
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE NONPROFIT
SHOULD POST THAT ON THE WEBSITE
[inaudible]
YEAH IT'S PEOPLE SAY WELL WE
DON'T NEED THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE
A HIGH IRS FORM MY NINE NINE AND
WE HAVE TO POST THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO FIND THOSE I
DON'T THINK ANY ANY STAFFER OF
TALK TO IN THE BUILDING DOESN'T
KNOW HOW TO FIND ELSEWHERE ST
POSTED ON THE WEBSITE IT'S JUST
CLEAR AND TRASPARENT.
PUBLIC MONEY BEING SPENT.
THE SECOND THING IS WE'RE SAYING
IN TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT THAT THE ARE IF RESOURCE
CENTERS.
ARE GONNA CHANGE OPERATIONS.
THAT THE PEOPLE SHOULD JUST.
SO SO THAT THE CLIENTS AREN'T
HARMED YOU SHOULD RETAIN THE
STAFF FOR LONG ENOUGH. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TRANSITION HAPPENS
AND THE SPOOF WAY THAT DOESN'T
HURT THE CLIENTS.
WE DO THAT FOR WORKERS AND
GROCERY STORES.
AND WE DO THAT FOR WORKERS WHO
WERE JANITORS. TO NOT DO IT FOR
THE CLIENTS IN THE WORKERS AND
REGIONAL CENTERS JUST SEEMS
WRONG.
NOW THAT'S ALL I KNOW I WONDER
IF INTRODUCED TO THE CURRENT ROW
HOLE WHO IS OUT TWELVE YOUR
EMPLOYEE IT TURNED REGIONAL
CENTER.
GETTING MEAN EVERYONE.
I GUESS MY NAME'S KRAMER HOA I
AM OF SERVICE COORDINATOR TWELVE
YEARS DEREK KERN REGIONAL
CENTER.
I'M ALSO THE CHAPTER PRESIDENT
OF THE UNION THAT IS THERE --
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH A LOT AND
RECENTLY THEY HAVE HIRED A NEW
SERVICE COORDINATORS.
IN THE LAST I WANT TO SAY THREE
TO FOUR MONTHS.
HOWEVER OUR CASELOADS ARE STILL
IN THE HUNDREDS --
WE ARE NOT SEEM AN ME --
FOUND COMING DOWN ON THOSE
CASELOADS AND DATA DOES THAT
DOES THAT HOW OF HIGH CASELOADS
ARE STILL --
WHAT CAN I SAY I?
HAVING HARD TIMES.
GETTING TO ALL THOSE SERVICES
FOR OUR CLIENTS AND THE MAIN
THING IS THAT OUR CLIENTS
SEPARATE THE FAMILY SUPPER.
WHEN YOU HAVE SUCH A HUGE TURN
AROUND?
AND YOU'RE YOU HAVE CLIENTS TO
HAVE BEEN WITH THE COURT MADE A
FOR OVER.
THAT SAY FORTY YEARS DEPEND ON
THAT THE AGE OF THE CLIENT.
AND THEN TO HAVE SOME ONE BRAND
NEW WHO.
DOESN'T KNOW THE HISTORY OF THE
FAMILY BECAUSE THERE HASN'T BEEN
THAT.
TIME OF TRANSITION --
IT'S IT TAKES A LOT ON OUR
CLIENTS AND FAMILIES AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE JUST DON'T WE
JUST ON'T WANT TO SEE AND WE
WERE AND WE CONTINUE TO SEE
THAT.
SOME I AM HOPING THAT YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF WHAT DEPTH ONLY --
HELPLESS AND HOW BE AND
TRANSPARENCY.
BUT THEY SAY THEY'RE DOING.
WHICH IS NOT ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GOING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING AB WESTLING I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES.
AND FIRST OFF JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT REGIONAL CENTERS PROVIDE
CARE AND SERVICE COORDINATION TO
OVER THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR GOAL IS A SHARED GOAL
WITH SCO YOU AS WELL AS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND THAT'S TO SERVE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OFTEN
TIMES THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY WELL.
THIS BILL AS MISTER HARRIS
BRIEFLY STATED WOULD DO A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT WOULD REQUIRE
POSTING ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ON REGIONAL CENTER WEBSITES.
RELATED --
TO COMPENSATION FOR MANAGERIAL
STAFF.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES NOTED IN
ITS OPPOSITION LETTER THAT
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IS BROADER THAN THE
IRS REQUIREMENTS FOR OTHER
PRIVATE TAX EXEMPT ORGANIZATIONS
AND IS NOT JUSTIFIED.
AND WE AGREE WITH THAT POSITION
REGIONAL CENTER WEBSITE ALREADY
CONTAIN FULL AUDIT REPORTS.
THEY CONTAIN FULL SALARY SCALES
AND MUCH MORE ROBUST INFORMATION
THAT IS ALREADY REQUIRED FOR
MANY NON PROFITS AND AT SOME
POINT WE NEED TO SAY THAT ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH [inaudible]
SECONDLY. ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE HAVEN'T DISCUSSED THIS
EVENING.
IS THAT CONTRACTS FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE TERMINATED VERY
INFREQUENTLY IN FACT THE LAST
TIME THAT WE COULD FIND WAS.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND STATURE
IT REQUIRES THAT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IS TO TERMINATE IT A
REGIONAL CENTER CONTRACT.
THAT IT FIRST TESTED DETERMINE
IT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE PERSON BEING SERVED BY THE
REGIONAL CENTER.
SO IT'S NOT DONE FOR CAPRICIOUS
ARBITRARY REASONS.
AS I NOTED WE HAVE A LOT OF
COMMON GROUND WITH SCO YOU AS
WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT IN THIS.
IN OUR COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THEIR FAMILIES IN
INFANTS AND TODDLERS AT RISK
RECEIVED THE BEST SERVICES
POSSIBLE.
WE ALSO AGREE WITH.
S. YEAH YOU BUT THE DEDICATED
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE OVER WORKED
AND UNDER COMPENSATED
[inaudible]
BUT THIS BILL ISN'T THE RIGHT
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES.
REGIONAL CENTERS PROVIDE A
VARIETY OF DIRECT SERVICES.
INCLUDING SERVICE COORDINATION
INTAKE CLINICAL SERVICES BUT
THEY ALSO PROVIDE A LOT OF
INDIRECT SERVICES.
INSURING PROVIDER MATCHING
QUALITY ASSURANCE AND PAYING
BILLS FOR CONTRACTED SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
ALL OF THAT CAN ONLY HAPPEN IN A
STABLE ORGANIZATION AND A STABLE
ORGANIZATION IS BETTER FOR
CLIENTS FAMILIES STAFF AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU CAN YOU WRAP UP YOUR
COMMENTS I WOULD.
THIS BILL WOULD PLACE
SIGNIFICANT LIMITATIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS ON THE STATE'S
AUTHORITY TO CONTRACT FOR
SUCCESSOR SERVICES.
AND WOULD HAMPER THE SUCCESSOR
AND IN SHORT TIE THEIR HANDS.
WE AGREE AS A NOTED WITH S. YEAH
YOU THAT THERE ARE NEEDS TO
ADDRESS S. THAT THERE ARE NEEDS
TO ADDRESS OPERATIONS FUNDING
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS.
BUT REGIONAL CENTER FUNDING IS
BASED ON CASELOADS AND BASED ON
A FORMULA BASED ON THAT.
AND SO AS MISS ROWBOAT NOTED.
CASELOADS IN THE HUNDREDS SOME
OF THAT ARISES FROM [inaudible]
HOME.
FROM DIFFICULTIES IN REGIONAL
CENTER STRIKING A BALANCE
BETWEEN WHAT TO PAY STAFF IN THE
SIZE OF CASELOADS AND WHAT WE
FOUND WAS.
THAT WHEN WE ALL WORK TOGETHER
SUCH AS IN THE ABX TO ONE
STATUTE FROM A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO.
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO A FINAL
SIGNIFICANT MONEY INTO THE
SYSTEM AND ABLE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL COMPENSATION FOR THE
DEDICATED EMPLOYEES AND STAFF UP
REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL AS
SERVICE PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CAME A SEE I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND QUESTIONS FROM --
THE MEMBERS [inaudible]
MR DEMINT.
THE COMMAND SHARE --
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR I'M
THANK YOU SO OF YOUR TESTIMONY
FEEL WORK --
ACTUALLY I ALSO SERVED AS A
SERVICE COORDINATOR AT A
REGIONAL CENTER.
ALMANAC HAD THE OPPORTUNITY BOTH
SERBS CORNER AND A MANAGER AND I
SUPPORT.
WHAT THIS BILL IS ASKING ABOUT I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR FOR YOU ALL
AND FOR THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM
ARKA --
BICU.
I WAS WONDERING WHAT DROVE THE
INTEREST IN THIS I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHEN.
I CAN IMAGINE HAS THERE BEEN A
PLACE WHERE YOU'VE SEEN THE
OPERATIONS CHANGE AND THE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES WERE
ASSIGNED TO ANOTHER AGENCY AS
ONE UNDERSTANDS OR SOME.
CONTRACTING OUT OR SOMETHING
THAT'S HAPPENING THAT WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT [inaudible]
SO.
THROUGH THE CHAIR --
LOOK WHAT WE'VE HAD OCCURRED
AGAIN CAN.
THE A CURRENT REGIONAL CENTER
AND THERE'S BEEN.
A LOT OF BUT UPSET THERE AND A
BAD NOW AUDIT AND BAD OUTCOMES
AND THERE'S AND THAT DEPARTMENTS
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS THAT.
BUT PART OF THEIR ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS IT.
WAS TO BRING IN SOMEONE WHO RAN
IN.
CENTRAL VALLEY REGIONAL CENTER.
WHO WAS ANTI UNION TO TRY AND
TALK TO THE UNION ABOUT LOWER
AND LOWER AND THEIR WAGES AND
THEY AGREED THAT THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY DID THAT BUT THAT
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE TIME WAS
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE?
THE NONPROFIT KERN AND HAND
CONTROL OVER THAT. TO THE
PRESIDENT REGIONAL CENTER.
AND THEY'RE TWO DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS AND THREATENING PEOPLE
LIKE THAT CAUSED HUGE UPSET BOTH
IN THE CLIENTS AND IN THE STAFF
AND A CO STAFF TURNOVER DID.
BEGIN TO OCCUR.
SO WE THOUGHT THAT WAS THE WRONG
WAY TO GO.
AND THE WAY TO DEAL WITH THESE
THINGS IN A RATIONAL AND SANE
MANNER AND OPEN TRANSPARENT
MANNER AND SO THE BILL ATTEMPTS
TO DO THAT.
AND THANK I'M SORRY THAT
[inaudible]
THAT'S WHY.
THAT I WAS GOING TO SAY IS I
PRETTY MUCH THINK THING IT'S
TROUBLED --
PASTURE WITH THIS REGIONAL
CENTER THE STATE ACTUALLY CAME
AND TRIED TO FIX THAT.
AYE THEY BROUGHT IN ANOTHER
AGENCY TO HELP ASSIST WITH THAT.
THIS LEGISLATION HERE IS TRYING
TO SEEK ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE TAXPAYER
FUNDS ARE BEING USED. TO HELP
FIND ALL OF THE DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS INCLUDING CURTAINS
[inaudible]
AND AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
INCREASE AT TRANSPARENCY SO THAT
WE CAN HOPEFULLY BE THAT BRIDGE
AND THEY COLLABORATE COME
TOGETHER.
LIKE THE OPPOSITION SAID WHEN
PEOPLE COME TOGETHER I THINK
GREAT OUTCOMES HAPPEN.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT TRANSPARENCY
THAT TRUST ABOUT HOW THE
FINANCES ARE WORKING FOR A
TROUBLED REGIONAL CENTER?
I BELIEVE YOU'RE ON THAT PATH
THEY SEE THIS LEGISLATION AS A
PATH TOWARDS THOSE ARE ALSO BUT
SOLUTION SO THAT WE CAN.
SERVE OUR DEVELOPMENT TOTALLY
DISABLED COMMITTEE THANK YOU
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION I
YOU KNOW I WORKED FOR TWO
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS.
THEY ARE VERY LARGE AGENCIES
WITH A LOT OF I'M CAPACITY AND
I'VE NEVER HEARD.
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES I'M GLAD
THAT YOU BROUGHT THE BILL IN
THAT YOU'VE MADE US AWARE --
YOU KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE
EIGHT IT LOOKS LIKE A MERGER
THESE ARE PUBLIC RESOURCES AND
SO THERE SHOULD BE COMMUNITY
MEETINGS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO GET INPUT.
AND TO GET INPUT ON THE SERVICES
THAT'S THE WHOLE THING THAT REAL
CENTERS BASED ON IS THE PEOPLE
SERVE GET TO GIVE HIM PUTS A
THANK YOU FOR RAISING IT.
MEN CHAIR OF THE SECURITY OF
THIS ANYBODY HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FELT NO SERVICES IF
SO CAN WE HEAR FROM THEM TO THE
DOES SOME OF THE SOME OVERSIGHT
ISSUES THAT.
THAT NEED --
TO TO BE PROVIDED IF NOT COULD
WE DO DO YOU KNOW STAFF THAT
COMMUNICATION SEND THE MESSAGE
THAT THERE'S AN EXPECTATION THAT
WE'LL HEAR FROM THEM AT SOME
POINT.
IN THIS COMMITTEE --
TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON HOW
THESE RESOURCES ARE BEING
MONITORED IN THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT WE SERVE.
AND STAFF --
ARE NOT FINDING ITSELF IN THESE
VOLATILE SITUATIONS YES
ABSOLUTELY THANK AHEAD A
CHATTERBOX IN JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION TO OUR TO THE ARGUMENT
WAS ENDED UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORT.
YOU MENTION AB TWO THAT'S WHY
I'M THERE WITH THE BILL OF THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL ABSOLUTELY
PROUD YOUR SIR --
VERY PROUD THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
SOUGHT PROVIDE.%
BUT VIET FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT PEOPLE DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES AFTER WHAT HAD BEEN
DECADES OF CUTBACKS YEAH I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS WHERE ARE WE IN
OUR CASE MANAGEMENT COMPLIANCE I
KNOW THAT EVERY TIME THAT WE ARE
AT A COMPLIANCE.
THAT WE PAY FINES TO I THINK TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PIECE OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THAT
WE ACTUALLY DON'T PAY FEES TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR ANY
SORT OF FINES --
THAT WE RUN THE RISK ALWAYS OF
ANY TIME YOU'RE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH ANY FEDERAL
EXPECTATIONS OF IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TAKING NOTICE OF THAT
AND COMING IN AND TAKING
CORRECTIVE ACTION.
THAT HAPPENED LAST IN THE
NINETEEN IN THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE -- AND
AWARE THAT MORNING BUT THAT
STILL AND THAT HURTS MY HEART
[inaudible]
I WAS.
A LOT OF YEARS.
OF WAR THOUGH --
IN THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID COME
IN AND IT COST THE STATE ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE COURSE
OF FIVE YEARS.
WE'RE CURRENTLY ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED SERVICE COORDINATOR
SHORT -- I
THINK SLIGHTLY LESS THAN THAT
AND ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THAT
IS THAT OUR SYSTEM CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE TREMENDOUS GROWTH IN
CASELOAD.
AND ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE IS THAT FOR EACH CASE
MANAGEMENT POSITION THAT'S
FUNDED.
THERE IT'S BUDGETED --
THERE'S ONLY SUFFICIENT FUNDING
FOR ABOUT 60% OF A POSITION SO
AS THE STATE CONTINUES TO GROW
IN IS THE CASELOAD --
OVERALL CASELOAD OF THE STATE
CONTINUES TO GROW IN THE SYSTEM
--
WE SAW SOME INITIAL REALLY FROM
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
THAT -- IN
THAT YEAR AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS THAT --
NEW.
EXPECTATIONS FOR NEW POSITIONS
ARE PUTTING ADDITIONAL STRESS ON
THE SYSTEM I I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
ANYTHING THAT'S THE FUNDED IS
SORT OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY IF YOU'RE ONLY
GETTING 60% OF WHAT YOU NEED.
THAT'S THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY I AGREE WITH THAT
I GUESS I WOULD JUST ASK THAT IF
THERE IS A PLAN. FOR HOW TO GET
THE STATE --
TO CLOSE TO A 100% OF COMPLIANCE
WE DON'T FIND OURSELVES.
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN TO PAY
BILLION DOLLARS OR WHATEVER IT
IS THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GET LOVE IT THROUGH THE CHAIR
THEN WITH THE CHAIRS --
PERMISSION TO ASK THAT YOU ALL
WOULD ALSO WORK WITH PDS PROVIDE
AN UPDATE ON WHERE THE STAFFING.
PLANS ARE TO GET US UP TO A UP
TO FULL COMPLIANCE ABSOLUTELY
DATE TO THE CHAIR'S OFFICE.
CAN I JUST ADD ONE MORE THING
AND IF THERE IS NO CURRENT
PROPOSAL NOR AM I AWARE OF AN
ACTIVE PROPOSAL AT ANY POINT IN
THIS PROCESS TO MERGE THOSE TWO
REGIONAL CENTERS.
I JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD AS WELL AS THERE IS
ACTUALLY STATUTE BUT IT --
THAT MANDATES THAT CURRENTLY --
CATCHMENT AREA IS COMPRISED OF
THOSE THREE COUNTIES THAT IT
SERVES ITS THE ONLY REGIONAL
CENTER WITH STATUTE TO THAT
EFFECT.
APPRECIATE CLARIFICATION DOES
SALAD THEY'RE EXPERIENCING SOME
ORGANIZATIONAL DIFFICULTIES THAN
I KNOW THAT ARE TO HAS RESOURCES
AND OTHERS THAT THEY NEED TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
SO THE PEOPLE THEY ARE SERVE
WELL AND PEOPLE WHO SERVE PEOPLE
THERE ALSO WERE SUPPORTING AND
THEY HAVE A PERMANENT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR NOW WHO IS PHENOMENAL
AND HAS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS FIELD --
ACTUALLY CAME FROM NORTH BAY
REGIONAL CENTER --
SO.
WE THINK THINGS ARE ON THE RIGHT
FOOTING AT THIS POINT MAKES A
CLARIFICATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER THURMAN WILL GO ON AND ON
SANDALS UP THAT INFORMATION
OVER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
NO.
THANK YOU I'M I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY IT BRINGS I'M ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE POTENTIAL TO
ENSURE CONTINUITY OF CARE AND I
THINK THAT'S MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF THIS BILL THE CONTINUITY OF
CARE -- FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES --
IN THE RARE INSTANCE SAYS A BAD
WORD THE REGIONAL CENTER LOSES
THE CONTRACTS THE OPERATIONAL
CONTRACT SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
WITH THAT --
LOCAL AND TAKE --
I'M SORRY YOU MAY CLOSE TO
SPECIFICALLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
CAN CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI I KNOW WHAT I'M
GONNA.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
THERE'S THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE DEBILIS OUT THE
BILL A IS BOUND TO
APPROPRIATIONS FIVE TO ONE THANK
YOU AND JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
--
WE HAVE TO BUILD UP TODAY PLEASE
NOTE THAT WE WILL NOT BE HEARING
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR JACKSON TODAY.
THANK YOU.
AND WITHOUT EYES SENATOR DELGADO
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM HONORED TO PRESENT MY FIRST
BILL OF SENATE BILL TEN TWELVE
WHICH GIVES CITIES THE ABILITY
TO CREATE A HOMELESS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY.
PERSONNEL TEAM AND M. D..
BUT WHEN A COUNTY ISN'T ABLE TO
PROVIDE US SUPPORT WITHIN THE
CITY.
SO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO BECAME
LAW INTO DOESN'T SEVENTEEN AND
IT GAVE COUNTIES THE SAME
ABILITY. TO CREATE HOMELESS A
MBTS HOWEVER NOT EVERY COUNTY
HAS THE CAPACITY TO CREATE
MANAGE AN MBT FOR EVERY CITY
WITHIN. FOR EXAMPLE LA COUNTY
HAS EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES CITIES
WITHIN IT THERE'S NO WAY FOR LA
COUNTY TO CREATE AND MANAGE AN
MDT FOR EVERY CITY THAT HAS THE
NEED.
SOME CITIES FOR EXAMPLE ONE AGO
OF ABOVE AND BEYOND THE PLAN
THAT THE COUNTY HAS OUTLINED.
SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO FILL GAPS
--
AND NOT DUPLICATE SERVICES THAT
ARE ALREADY THERE.
AND I THINK IT'S A RESPONSIBLE
WAY THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE BUDGET FOR
HOMELESSNESS IS USED IN A
PRODUCTIVE MANNER.
S. B. TEN TWELVE HAS THE SUPPORT
OF THE LEAGUE OF CITIES LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ACCEPT OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS ON PAGE.
FOR A OF THEIR ANALYSIS AND
THINK THE CHAIR AND HER STAFF
FOR THE HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WILL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE BILL.
KICK WE HAVE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT YES GOOD EVENING I'M
CHAIR MEMBERS SHE'S RIGHTLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE US SENATE ABOUT OWES
EFFORTS ON THIS --
TO THE LEGISLATURE --
DID AMAZING THING THEY SHARE
WITH FIVE HER MILLION DOLLARS
DIRECTED CITIES AND COUNTIES I
THINK WHAT YOU'VE SEEN OUT OF
THAT IS YOU OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES RAISING THEIR HAND SAME
PLEASE WE WANT TO DO ALL WE CAN
DO.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES GET FOLKS OFF
THE STREETS AND THIS BILL IS A
REFLECTION OF THAT CITIES WANT
TO FILL IN WHERE WE CAN.
AND WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE OF
THE AMENDMENTS WE THINK THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ADD LANGUAGE TO
TO THE SECTION OTHER IT'S
IMPORTANT WE DON'T DUPLICATE
SERVICES OF THE COUNTIES
PROVIDED.
ARM HOWEVER DID THAT THE
DELETION OF BIT OF SECTION BE I
THINK WE YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT A
TERRIBLY THRILLED BUT BUILT THIS
IS GOOD FOR STEP.
UP AND WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THAT WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANYWAY THAT'S IS IN OPPOSITION.
K. HEARING NONE OF I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND --
DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY NOPE [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO TRY
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU --
FOR ALLOWING YOUR FIRST BILL TO
BE HERE IN THIS --
COMMITTEE AND IT'S A REALLY GOOD
BILL AYE AYE --
AYE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE
TO USE THIS IN OUR COUNTY AS
WELL.
THANK YOU YOU.
IF I MIGHT ADD THIS THIS IS
ACTUALLY A VERY PERSONAL ISSUE
ISSUE TO ME --
MY UNCLE WAS FEATURED AS THE
STORY OF THE THE RISE AND
NOTHING HOMELESSNESS AND LA
TIMES LAST YEAR.
SO WHEN I SAW THAT STORY AND SAW
HIS PICTURE ALL OVER IT AND YOU
THAT I HAD TO DO.
SOMETHING TO WORK ON IT SO I
THINK THE THE LEAGUE FOR BRING
IT FORWARD AND YOU'RE A HOPEFUL
YOUR COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS GET THINK YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MEANT CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
IF REVIEW I DR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
BRANCH.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I THE BILL IS NOW
OFFICIALLY KGO THE BILL MOVES ON
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR ON THAT
SIX ZERO VOTE THANK YOU Q..
YES SHE DID.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT IS
THE END WILL ADJOURN HUMAN
SERVICES ACT --
SIX THIRTY FIVE PM THINK YOU